[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what's right
it definitely was it was fun because i
love
justin bieber i love his music so it was
fun
and it was nice to like dance to a
little canadian heartthrob
why would i say that i love that he's
just
covered in tattoos and i want to get
bieber's face tattooed on me
because he's that cute crazy
i don't know how his wife would feel
about a tattoo of him on you but i'm all
for it
she can get a tattoo of my boyfriend i
feel honored
i was actually stopped by the nine
because i totally respect her feedback
and agree with her feedback and that's
something i've been trying to work on
every week
so for her to say that just kind of
justified all of my feelings and
everything artem's been telling me about
how
he believes i can attack it and so it's
i don't know why i'm not it's
i i think it's the dancing in heels it's
very neat for me but
i was so grateful that she gave an eye
[Music]
sorry
i think it's been great during this
video i think we started really really
strong and i feel like we keep
getting better and better and better
it's like every single week as you look
in the sports that we've been getting
we're always progressing
and even this week we got the same
scores as last week it's still a huge
um like an appreciation from our end
because we know how difficult this week
was
i feel like every practice at this point
i'm like
what else are you gonna bring to me i
don't know uh but i also said in another
interview like having that injured ankle
kind of set me up for
like mentally being stronger through the
whole
process of everything because now i'm
like i think i have a couple ribs out
and tickles like i don't care it's no
nothing compared to the ankle pain i
felt so
um i feel like every week i'm just
believing in what my body can do